President Trump on his way to a second
high stakes summit with North Korean
leader Kim jong-un the pair set to face
face meet later this week in Vietnam
president Trump looking to continue
progress made during the first sit-down
and is optimistic North Korea will
eventually give up its news I think we
can have a very good a very good summit
I think we'll have a very tremendous
summit we want the nuclearization and I
think he'll have a country that will set
a lot of records for speed in terms of
an economy meanwhile the mainstream
media is already trashing Trump and
throwing cold water on any positive
outcome from the talks is this visit
just for lack of a better word a
romantic visit the president say that he
loved Kim jong-un again this weekend
this love in pieces did he I don't know
do they send each other it's so
disturbing garden my worry George is
that this negotiation this summit may be
a dud
you're saying the president's going to
get played I think the president's just
looking for good press I mean let's just
be frank
he felt like he got a good good press
after the last one and he figures
another photo-op might might do that
great here's how you know how bias the
mainstream media is when he was tough on
Kim then he was gonna create a nuclear
holocaust and now when he is engaging
with Kim it's a romance yes it's
interesting how this criticism is
bordering on homophobia it's the same
thing they did with Trump and Putin
remember they had them making out it's
like only on the Left can you get away
with these kinds of slights that they
think is somehow humorous if any of us
had done something like that would say a
liberal like President Obama we would be
who is actually exchanging letters with
the Ayatollah and giving them cash so
here's the here's the thing you got to
address the human rights abuses you got
it you can't just ignore that but it is
possible to pursue the external threats
which are nuclear nuclear weapons
separating that from the internal
injustice is within a country because
that takes a lot that's a longer pace
there are 77 countries that criminalize
homosexuality we still deal with them so
you've got it you've got it you can deal
with these seems set but separately the
external threat the internal injustice
but if you conflate them which is what
CNN is doing putting them together you
never solve an external threat because
you're gonna be too busy arguing over
what internally is going on in their
country therefore you will never ever be
able to say reduce the nuclear threat of
North Korea and then every day will be
January 13th
you know 2018 and Hawaii with the
ballistic missile threat can I just go
to all jordan peterson on for a minute
whatever that means this whole this
whole North Korea gambit is audacious
audacious and to most people absurd but
to get to someplace realistic and
practical you have to start with a
fantasy for example they get to
astronomy you had to start with
astrology that's what jordan peterson
saying and i do think it needed in a
political CEO to come up with something
so absurd and a simple philosophy of
let's see what happens because no one
else was going to do this and so we
we've all moved on from the absurd
notion of engaging north korea because
we're actually seeing progress so what
you're seeing is the beginning of a
fantasy to something real and to one the
left should embrace this because you can
throw it back at us and go what about
free health care what about the new
green deal those are fantasies that
start audaciously and then move to
something practical so in a weird way
donald trump is the guy you go to about
green deals and free health care I'm all
for Trump embracing the green New Deal
something crazy move to something good
dude I listen to you what's wrong with
our day and yeah I'm sure the people who
are green new dealers are listening st.
Gregg unbelievable no that's that's my
point my point is that when you have
somebody like Trump you don't know what
to expect this is just one of those
things and to just sit there and keep
making jokes like morning bozo you know
it's a but on the other hand you do have
people it's not you guys you aunt Jessie
says the media but I don't think dan
coates
is right yeah dan coates is the national
security he's not saying anything
cynical and sarcastic that yes they've
stopped with the rockets and the nuclear
testing but we haven't seen any progress
towards denuclearization and that's
something that they want to accomplish
in Vienna
but they had stop they had pledged to
stop the nuclear testing before the
first meeting I think their clear-eyed
about what to expect from the North
Koreans aren't they they know is not a
regime yeah it always tells the funniest
part of that montage for me is that he
would be doing this because he's looking
for good press good press from home he's
gonna be a failure I think he should be
careful I I think Trump sometimes talks
a little bit too much I think he comes
you do I do I think he's very optimistic
he wants to come out and he is the deal
maker he thinks of himself like that he
thinks of himself as someone who's gonna
get stuff done that other presidents may
not have been able to accomplish in some
cases that's true but I think when he
says these really bold things like you
know chairman Kim will make a wise
decision you don't know if he's gonna
make a wise decision
don't put that stuff out there that's
like Mexico's gonna pay for the wall
hold back a little bit it's very easy to
just say look I'm going in there with
the best of intentions I hope for deep
nuclei zation it's gonna be good for
their economy I hope they take my side
on this I don't know what's gonna happen
let's hope for the best and see how it
goes when you make those statements it
makes you feel then obligated to cave a
little bit to get a deal done
because it doesn't do him any justice so
I would just say be a little more
cautious about it know who you're
dealing with know that this is a
dictator that's not always reliable that
does hide missile sites it's not like
you're dealing with an ally here you're
not and just hold some of that back and
obviously no matter what he does the
media is gonna rail against and if he if
he didn't go he would be someone who
didn't care about diplomacy so he can't
win with them regardless that's a big
joke I have to go out of character here
oh boy is he gonna tell the truth
Trump bashing at this table has to stop
look I I don't think that when he says
he will make this decision about
economic prosperity that he's expecting
it he's giving kim jeong-hoon a choice
he's saying this is the only choice for
you we're putting this on the table we
are not coming in militarily right now
even though I put that option on the
table before but this is really the
choice that you should make and he knows
exactly who he's dealing with he knows
he's dealing with a dictator who loves
movies who loves Western culture who
loves Western sports and he's trying to
incentivize him to say look you can be a
western superpower you can
engage in all of these new cultural
things to your country without having
regime change we're not talking about
taking you out man
we're just saying you can stay as long
as you decide to embrace these cultural
norms clean it up a little bit stop
threatening us and then we can move
forward but eventually the white house
is going to get impatient the president
has said that he's not in a hurry xym in
a timeline but eventually they're going
to want something in return
other than just stopping the missile
testing and that is something that the
second summit will hopefully provide and
him talking to him and saying look we've
had this agreement you've exchanged no
missile testing but now it's time to
talk about your nuclear program and the
intelligence community does say that you
are still building sites you're not
getting rid of them and it's about time
that you stop doing those things we're
doing this in good faith and you seem
not to be doing it in return I think I
think you have to be you have to be
skeptical of course about this it would
be crazy if you weren't skeptical but
again it's people were skeptical about
the moonshot right and when people talk
about going to Mars that's crazy but
people think about this you think about
these things ending the Korean War we
weren't talking about ending the Korean
War two years ago that's going to happen
the Korean War is going to end and it's
gonna it and that has a lot to do with
this insane process this is a foreign
policy moonshot it's gonna take time I
think the Korean War could take decades
but we know it's going on so I was
skeptical about George Clooney's to kill
we can all change our mind what are we
putting on the table is what you're hear
from people in Washington say oh so
we're gonna end the Korean War for what
are we're going to give a diplomatic
what do you need station okay this is
what their time the possibility that we
recognized North Korea as a nuclear
state why would we do that
I mean you have Gina Hoff CIA you have
dan coates saying these guys have no
intention to abandon their nuclear
ambitions
tell you what we're not gonna do what
we're not gonna send them pallets and
pallets of Kent gold in the dead of
night we didn't do we did it with Iran
all right